on a bitter cold Christmas Eve one Dark
Soul is selected for Redemption by the
ghosts of Christmas past present and yet
to come a tradition that continues to
this very Night
Like A Christmas Carol yes yes if you
would just let me get this outfit so out
of all the people on the planet
murderers people who do gender reveal
parties I'm the guy you're gonna hunt
you know what forget it
I told you the guy is a level 20 band in
the Dickens come on I can take this guy
I'm your Ghost of Christmas present
I'm not watching your dramatic
re-encrapment hey I'm haunting you you
can't just run away from me when I'm
haunting you hello
I believe he can be a positive force for
mankind and he's got his hands all over
everything yeah I wish mod are you
texting HR no
people don't change we got a runner
that's just fun to watch
I'm here to change into being a more
positive force for Humanity
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah you photoshop yourself into these
pictures of my executive VP thanks so
oh you want that what I want is for you
to shut up and let me do my job is there
a Ghost of Christmas grumpy because you
could do that job
Jingle Bells together
this is where real change begins
Oh that's oh he's dead yeah he's dead no
no he's fine he's good well not a girl
anyway
[Music]